Ask your doctor about ENTRESTO.
>> AS THE COUNTRY RECOVERS FROM
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC WHITE
HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
MEMBER DOCTOR ANTHONY FAUCI IS
ISSUING THIS WARNING.
>> WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
KEEPING THE LID ON IT, KEEPING
THE BASELINE DOWN UNTIL WE GET A
VACCINE.
I BELIEVE WE WILL LIKELY GET A
VACCINE BY THE END OF THE YEAR,
BEGINNING OF 2021 AND THAT WILL
TURN IT AROUND AS WE NEED TO GET
TO THIS FALL AND WINTER BECAUSE
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
WILL: A PULMONOLOGIST JOINS US
TO REACT.
THOSE ARE STATEMENTS THAT HAVE
CAUSED SOME CONTROVERSY BY
ANTHONY FAUCI.
DO YOU AGREE WE NEED TO.
THE FLU SEASON?
>> WE ARE ALWAYS PREPARED AND
BECAUSE OF THE AND TO MAKE THE
SILVER LINING WE ARE MORE
PREPARED AND GOING THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC THEY HAVE RECORD LOW
LEVELS OF INFLUENZA.
BECAUSE WE ARE WEARING MASKS AND
KEEPING DISTANCE THIS WILL MAKE
A DENT IN HUGE NEW NUMBERS BUT
EVERYONE WANTING TO GET THEIR
FLU SHOT THIS WEEK.
>> PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED BY WHAT
HE MEANS ABOUT HUNKER DOWN, DOES
THIS MEAN MORE SHUTDOWNS?
WILL I BE INSIDE THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS?
WE WILL STAY TUNED TO SEE WHAT
HE MEANS TO SPECIFY.
WE HAVE TO FEW EXPERTS TALKING
ABOUT THESE UV LIGHTS THAT ARE
SAFE FOR HUMAN EXPOSURE, THEY
KILL VIRUSES AND BACTERIA ON
SURFACES, SOUNDS PROMISING AND
EXCITING BUT ONE THING THAT
OCCURRED TO ME IS ARE WE OVER
SANITIZING OURSELVES?
WITH THE IMMUNE SYSTEM THE WAY
YOU BUILD AN IMMUNE SYSTEM IS
YOU HAVE TO BE EXPOSED TO THINGS
IN SMALL DOSES OVER TIME SO IS
THERE A RISK OF OVER SANITIZING
OUR BODIES?
>> IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS BEEN WELL
TESTED AND PLACED IN A ROOM, IT
CAN KILL 99% OF ALL VIRUSES
WITHIN 25 MINUTES, THIS SHOULD
BE PERVASIVE.
WE’VE USED THIS FOR A LONG TIME
AND IT DOES NO HARM TO THE BODY,
DOESN’T EVEN PENETRATE THE CELLS
OF THE SKIN.
I’M IN FAVOR OF THAT.
ADD VENTILATION AND OTHER
FACTORS.
I’M NOT SURE I AGREE WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT ALL MEASURES IN THE
PANDEMIC AS OVERHEAD SIZING.
WE ARE LEARNING THERE ARE SO
MANY THINGS WE CAN MITIGATE AND
STILL HAVE A ROBUST IMMUNE
SYSTEM SO NOW.
I DON’T AGREE WITH THAT.
>> THAT IS GOOD AND INSIGHTFUL
INFORMATION.
I’M GLAD TO HEAR IT IS SAFE.
WE WILL SEE THIS PUT IN A LOT OF
JIM’S AND APARTMENT BUILDINGS